good morning belief nation today's
message is play for yourself over to you
LeBron James for me I understand that a
lot gets thrown upon my plate and a lot
gets thrown upon what I do so for me my
personal goals is to win championships
and at the end of my career what I was
able to accomplish will make me happy
and make me satisfy because I don't play
for I don't play for what people expect
for me to do anymore you know I want to
be the greatest of all time and that's
just my mindset wherever they lay me at
the end of my career and you know if
it's not 1 9 or 12 or whatever the case
might be Smitty I had a great time I'm
playing this game to a low to put too
many entrepreneurs do things because
their friends want them to do it their
parents want them to do it the rest of
their family want them to do it their
culture their society wants them to do
it and you're only really gonna have a
major impact you're only gonna really
have the success you're looking for
you're only gonna really have the money
and the the love and the atmosphere that
you want when you are doing something
that makes you come alive and you're
living your life instead of what other
people want you to do and I get how that
can be hard sometimes if you are in a
family of lawyers and there's 10
generation of lawyers and you are
expected to be the next person to be a
lawyer and follow in that tradition then
it's hard to break free and it takes a
lot of guts to do it but it's going to
take a lot of guts to chase your dream
it's going to take a lot of guts to have
a big impact it's going to take a lot of
guts to overcome all the other obstacles
that are come along your path this is
just the first of many to come the key
is to stop caring as much about what
other people are thinking about you and
live your path because it's the right
path for you not the right path for them
I recently brought on Alex who helps me
run this business Toronto dance salsa
and one of the things that I just can't
help doing is seen
more in people right I believe in people
I see something better in them than what
they see in themselves I can't help it
it's part of what I do and being around
me you're gonna get an injection of
believe it just is going to happen and I
challenge people to think bigger and
step outside their comfort zone and try
to be the best version of themselves and
Alex said hey don't you care what people
think about you when you challenge them
because they may not all would be
receptive to it and the short answer is
no I don't really care and it's because
I know my intention is good right and
you should know that your intention is
good like you may not be right it may
not be the right answer you might make
mistakes but if the intention is good
and it's in your heart then you have to
go and do it I don't know if you can
ever completely ignore the pressures
from outsiders from parents and family
from friends I don't know if that's ever
totally possible at least for me but
with practice you get better at it and
better at it and better at it and it
comes from the realization understanding
that they may be coming from a place of
love and a desire to want to help you
out but following that path is not in
your best interest and the more you get
used to exercise in that muscle the less
you're gonna worry about what other
people are thinking and the more you're
gonna play or yourself so the question
of the day today is I'm curious to know
how do you play for yourself leave it in
the comments below I'm gonna join the
discussion thank you guys for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events press
nespresso TV go